[Music]  hey you gonna come in the water with us  easy no I think I'm just going to kick  back and grab some Sun are you sure dude  it's going to be like the last good day  of the summer you guys go ahead  good go yeah  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  we went out there  [Music]  [Music]  you  thank you for watching  micro [ __ ] the end if you liked this  video remember to like this video go  down in the comments and let me know  what your favorite micro [ __ ] has been  if you missed any episodes I'll leave a  link to the playlist so you can go check  out any of them remember to subscribe to  Suzie's world for new Horrors every  other week ring that death bell for  notifications and I'll see you in the  next one assuming we both survived